bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin alors d'abord ceux de
décision de la part de la justice est
assez rare que signifie ce jugement pour
la justice française
alors c'est effectivement un jugement
assez rare mais il permet à la justice
de constater ses fautes et ses lacunes
que d'ailleurs les victimes dénoncent
régulièrement c'est-à-dire que
lorsqu'elles vont dans un commissariat
et dépose plainte pour des faits de
violence conjugale ou pour réitération
de violence conjugale ou de menaces de
mort souvent les policiers ne des ne
prennent pas la plainte
il envoie vers un cahier de mains
courantes la victime ce père que elle va
indiquer les faits dans un des victimes
dans un cahier qui n'ai jamais transmis
au parquet et de surcroît les délais de
transmission des pelade quand elles sont
prises normalement ne sont pas transmis
en temps réel ou pour cuire la
république
donc on a ce problème là qui est de
l'effectivité de l'efficacité du droit
puisque la plainte n'est pas prise elle
n'est pas transmise et il n'y a pas de
réponse concernant soit une révocation
de contrôle judiciaire soit un bracelet
électronique soit un éloignement dans un
département qui lointains sont une
obligation d'habiter on a eu aussi des
foyers d'emmaüs qui était disposé à
accueillir des hommes violents a
bénéficié bénéficier de contrôle
socio-psychologique dalle est venue
également donc les dispositions qui
pourtant sont législatives et son
contenu dans le code de procédure pénale
ne sont absolument pas utilisés à leur
juste mesure par les services de police
donc c'est cela qu'a voulu démontrer la
le jugement et serment le coup de poing
sur la table qui est dit on a une
meilleure une très bonne législation des
meilleurs neurones et on n'utilise pas
on ne fait rien on laisse les femmes
allaient dans les commissariats et puis
ressortir en n'ayant absolument aucune
protection
il faut savoir quand même à peu près une
femme sur deux assassinés avaient déjà
déposé plainte et s'agissant de
la condamnation de l'état qui où il est
condamné à verser aux proches de la
victime donc une indemnité des dommages
et intérêts est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite de ce jugement
écoutez il n'y a pas de précédent
donc lorsque l'on créé une nouvelle
jurisprudence on effectivement quand
même heureux de ce que l'institution
judiciaire dit à l'institution
judiciaire d'être plus attentive et plus
efficace et plus protectrice mais
combien vaut combien comment évaluer le
coût d'une bord est là en l'espèce le
coup de trois morts on pourrait penser
dans une évolution future
les dommages intérêts pour être
effectivement plus élevé c'est un
problème général en droit français à
être victimes de viols amène à une
condamnation civile de bâtiments 30000
euros alors que toute la vie rêvée de
ces difficultés la perdre son père sa
mère et sa soeur
est ce que le préjudice moral d'un
montant de 75 mille euros pour ma
cliente est à la hauteur de 2,7 de cet
immense ce vide affectif qu'il va
désormais qui est désormais le sien
d'ailleurs depuis six ans maintenant et
pour l'état le fait d'avoir été
condamnés par la justice
cela signifie quoi ab je pense que
l'état devrait avoir peur puisque ce
précédent imposées et on peut s'attendre
à de multiples actions et cela
signifiait que cette lacune est pointé
du doigt
donc on demande à l'état de protéger ses
citoyens et en l'espèce et citoyenne
puisque lorsqu'une femme rentre dans un
commissariat et moins cru qu'un homme
donc cela signifie à l'état qu'il y a
finalement une discrimination qui est
posée à l'égard des femmes et que cette
discrimination doit cesser et c'est une
injonction qui lui fait puisque si
l'effet continu et bien on verra que les
tarifs il
lui aussi en état de récidive alors les
féminicides on en parle actuellement
avec lui ont finement vous vous craignez
la hausse des féminicides c'est
d'actualité est ce que les mesures
prises il te ment pour venir en aide aux
femmes dans le contexte actuel elles
sont suffisantes selon vous alors il y a
des de nouveaux outils ont été mis en
place notamment allé déposer plainte
et finalement dans une pharmacie pouvoir
les bosses et anne par texto ou par via
un ordinateur c'est intéressant mais ce
que l'on constate c'est que les
commissariats sont souvent fermés or ce
qui est important pour une victime c'est
comme d'aller déposer plainte
très rapidement et de ne pas passer par
l'intermédiaire de la pharmacie mais
d'aller déposer plainte et de faire en
sorte on en revient à ce qu'on se disait
que les services de police interviennent
à leur domicile et que le l'agresseur
soit interpellé placé en garde à vue et
éloignés par une injonction qui est de
ne pas se représenter au domicile et de
ne pas se représenter dans ce quartier
donc le problème de la fermeture des
commissariats pose la réelle question de
la protection effective parce qu'au delà
du fait que les femmes maintenant peur
et s'expriment à des tiers il faut là
aussi qu'il y ait une réponse pénale en
thorel qui n'existe pas ou peu
actuellement puisqu'il faudrait qu'un
guichet et que peut être un guichet
unique et spécialisé sur les violences
faites aux femmes fonctionne 24 heures
sur 24 dans les commissariats puisque
finalement quand loeb d'or c'est
peut-être le moment où peuvent
s'échapper et à l'est dans la nuit
déposé plainte au commissariat
c'est peut-être ce moment là qui est à
privilégier
merci beaucoup avait la france ce matin
je rappelle que vous êtes avocate de la
famille de victime